-How are you?
-I'm good.
How are you?
-Good. I'm impressed.
I'm well.
I'm impressed with your energy
-You bet. Today's a good day
-You had a good day becaus
one of your former, I guess,
competitors for the nomination
Julian Castro,
endorsed you this morning.
-Yes, he did.
-That's really nice.
-It really is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It must be particularly nice to
get an endorsement from someon
who, you know,
has shared a stage with you,
has gone through the first few
months of this process with you.
How do you find out about
something like that happening?
-Well, you know, Julian and
have been friends
for a long time,
because we fight
for a lot of the same things
He has this remarkable story
about his life
and how he ended up
in public service.
And we're out there
fighting for people who don'
have a voice in our government
You know, we both see an America
that's working great if you're
rich, if you're powerful,
if you have an army of lawyers
and lobbyists.
But it's not working so grea
for everybody else.
And we feel like we've got thi
chance in 2020, this real chance
to be able to build an America
that works for everybody.
And Julian is just -- just
a great partner in this fight.
-Now, you mention partner,
because, of course,
anytime anyone
endorses someone else,
they go, "Oh, potential
running mate."
What do you have to --
-Way too presumptuous
to be talking about
that sort of thing.
-Yeah, you don't
rush into things.
You got to go slow
with stuff like that.
I want to talk about someone
that we're both,
I believe, fans of.
It's her birthday today --
Kate McKinnon,
who does an impression
of you on "SNL."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I was wondering --
I was wondering how you feel
about the impression.
What is it like seeing yoursel
on "Saturday Night Live"?
How do you feel Kate's doing
-You know, I have to say
she is really fabulous.
She's smart. She's engaged
You know, she brings
a lot of energy.
We wear the same jackets.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I want to give credit --
I want to do give quick credit
to the "SNL" wardrobe
department,
who makes more jackets than yo
can believe to match candidates.
-That's exactly right.
She does great.
And, look, here's the deal
Elect me President
of the United States,
and we get eight more year
of Kate McKinnon
on "Saturday Night Live."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, I --
I played John Kerry, and I think
it worked against him.
-See.
-Yeah.
I think it worked against him.
-I just got to say, Seth,
I know John Kerry.
You're no Kate McKinnon.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very --
That is very fair.
One of the things, as you figh
big money in politics,
as you fight
corruption in politics,
you stay away from big donors,
large-dollar donors.
So you have
smaller-dollar donors.
And you sort of famously
call a lot of them personally.
-I do.
-But I would have to imagine
a lot of them
don't believe it's you.
-[ Laughs ] It's true.
-What is it like when you --
I mean, what are
some of the things
that people say when you call?
-Well, a lot of people reall
start with serious cuss words.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
Sure. No, you know,
in the middle of dinner,
you don't want a fake
Elizabeth Warren calling you
-No, they just keep
saying things like, "Holy --
Oh, my -- Really?"
So there's a --
And then some of the best ones
I've actually been
cross-examined to prove
I'm not the newest version
of artificial intelligence
-Yeah, sure.
-And so I've had people ask me
like, "Okay, this is gonna b
a trick question.
When I say 'yes,'
you have to say 'no,'"
and -- in order
to get me to verify.
But, you know, this is
one of the best parts
of running a campaign like this.
I call people who make
$5 contributions and $25 -
In fact, go to
elizabethwarren.com tonight,
make some contributions,
I'll make some phone calls
-There you go!
-Okay? Let's do it!